[Musique]
vous moi ont donné tous témoins en cette
ère de pandémie il ya toutes sortes de
scénarios qui circulent sur internet
attachez vos tuques l'armée a ri c'est
ce qu'a déclaré une internaute en
relayant une vidéo où on aperçoit des
véhicules militaires transportés par
train on affirme que cette vidéo a été
tournée dans les environnements rien
même procédé même vidéo sur youtube et
l'internaute qui l'a téléverser évoque
la possibilité que l'armée soit déployée
à la grandeur du pays que les provinces
soient isolées les unes des autres et ce
n'est pas tout sur le site ouest yvonne
blog
on dit que cette vidéo est bien la
preuve que l'armée canadienne est sur le
point de déployer son opération laser un
plan de déploiement spéciale conçue par
l'armée canadienne en cas de pandémie
ouah prenons une grande respiration si
vous voulez bien jeff y est mon collègue
nous le rappeler dans un article récent
la 2e division de l'armée l'a spécifié
sur son compte twitter ces mouvements de
véhicules militaires sont dus à une
vraie opération militaire qui se tient
sur une base annuelle en alberta
l'opération mais paul resort pour des
raisons qu'on devine cette opération a
été annulé d'où ces mouvements de
véhicules militaires
fait intéressant à noter des vidéos
semblables tournée dans la région de
chicago en illinois aux états unis ont
aussi semer le doute et aussi mené à ce
genre d'hypothèse qui ont toutes été
démentie vous le voyez malgré la peur
ambiante malgré les craintes et les
appréhensions qu'on peut avoir
prenons le temps de vérifier ce qu'on
voit sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez
des doutes
écrivez-nous décrypteurs décrypteurs au
pluriel à commercial radio trait d'union
canada.ca est allé voir et lire
l'article de mon collègue des fillettes
au sujet de ces images de convois
militaires
[Musique]